hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
welcome back to tech tober good to be
with you again we're not even halfway
through this month so today is the
reveal of the huawei mate
20 Pro not to be confused with the p20
pro but the successor to the mate 10 Pro
which is the best they have for now
until the next the p30 Pro comes out
either way don't worry about that this
is the best that we always got right now
I apologize in advance for what may be
the worst lighting of any press room
I've ever been in but boom there it is
this is Huawei's newest creation oh and
also real quick
shameless plug if you guys are
interested in this shirt that I'm
wearing right now the optical flow aka
Joy Division inspired wavy line 3d
imprint looking trippy shirt it is live
in the merch store right now we're doing
a little quick 7 day drop from now till
the end of the week in honor of hitting
7 million subscribers on the channel
very recently shout to all you guys for
sticking around for that so if you want
to pick one of these up or you saw
something that you liked before it is
available and that is it link is down
below alright moving on to the phone so
Huawei has made a pretty interesting
design update to this mate flagship it's
feeling like a 20-18
notched bezel a screen on the front and
then a triple camera module with a big
flash now in the middle of the back it's
different and maybe it's just me over
analyzing the design as well way kind of
still tries to establish their flagship
DNA and their identity but this is
definitely the most Samsung feeling
phone they've ever made like if the
galaxy s 9 and the p20 Pro had a baby
especially with this Twilight triple
camera look this is probably what it
would look like so the curved glass and
the overall shape on the front is very
reminiscent of Samsung with the very
thin metal sides it's IP 68 certified
there's wireless charging a very small
chin at the bottom and extremely tiny
side bezels but then not just still
appear like the p20 pro with all the
front facing depth sensors for face
unlocking but then the mate 20 pro also
now has an in glass fingerprint reader
beating oneplus to the punch technically
and I'd say becoming the first major
big-name smartphone to do this not that
being first by a couple days or weeks is
a huge
deal but that's definitely awesome to
see it happening so fast this is a small
sensor out of the glass you know one
finger right in the lower middle like
we're gonna start to see but if we start
doing this more and more and it develops
and gets better this is how we end up
with bigger less expensive huge
fingerprint sensors under the glass that
are faster so this is an early
generation of that and the screen itself
is really nice it's a huge six point
four inch OLED and 19 and a half by 9
aspect ratio at 2k resolution so a
little taller than normal and any funny
flickering you may see again the
lighting in here is garbage and it
doesn't actually flicker like this to
the naked eye and realize but it's a
pretty bright great-looking screen on
first impression that's again curved on
the corners and bleeding over the slopes
of the edges and moving on to the sides
you get a colored power button which I
love to see this Twilight version has a
reddish orange power button which I like
that a lot and I'm not usually a bright
colored phone type of guy but I would
rock this for sure USB see at the bottom
no headphone jack and then around the
back is definitely the most iconic part
of this phones look the big triple
camera centered module with a huge flash
in there and the lack of branding up top
now a lot of you may remember the p20
pro in this twilight color already had a
triple camera setup on the back but that
was this weird regular camera then
telephoto then monochrome camera setup
this mate xx Pro is a much more on the
useful end just like the v40 with three
different focal lengths and normal lens
a super wide angle and a telephoto the
standard camera is a huge 40 megapixel
sensor with an F 1.8 aperture the
telephoto is an 8 megapixel camera at F
2.4 and the ultra wide is 20 megapixels
at F 2.2 so we'll have to get it in hand
in the studio and actually take pictures
and videos with it to see how good it is
but if it's anything like their previous
phone it'll probably absolutely crush
DxO mark and make headlines and you'll
have to decide how much to care about
that but one big point they've made
about it is how much they're leaning on
AI to not just make the camera better to
but to make the whole phone better to AI
will help with scene recognition again
with Master AI 2.0 to help recognize
more things in the camera more
accurately and tweak your photos based
on what you're taking a picture of but
then also this phone
a cure in 980 chipset which is a seven
nanometer chip and a 4200 milliamp hour
battery which is absolutely massive but
it will also use AI to help manage your
apps and help you get an even longer
battery life
apparently AI will also look at the
scene you're pointing at with the camera
and actually switch you automatically to
the wide-angle camera if it thinks
you'll need it which I'll be honest I
don't think I'm a fan of that I kind of
liked a little more manual control on
the camera but some people may be into
that but none of this none of this is
the coolest feature of this phone I did
save the best for last the coolest
feature of the huawei mate 20 pro is
something called reverse wireless
charging and it's exactly what it sounds
like so you know how this phone and many
others can charge the battery wirelessly
through the glass back well mate 20 Pro
has a setting you can turn on that will
turn it into a mobile battery bank then
you can wirelessly charge up other
phones with or whatever you want it's
cheap powered so you just turn it on in
the settings and I had my iphone there
as I was making this video so you just
rest something on the back of the Huawei
and it does start wireless charging the
iPhone so this is great you can be that
guy to actually literally offer to
wirelessly charge someone else's phone
oh what's that you're at 10% I got a
four thousand two hundred million power
battery I feel like I'll just let you
let you mooch a little bit you can
wirelessly charge that's cool in fact
you don't even have to be physically
touching wireless charging works through
a case works through a skin and works
even if you just hover the phone's a
centimeter apart man the the trolling
opportunities here or the helping
opportunities are gonna be huge but
anyway that's pretty much the main gist
of the mate 20 Pro I actually think this
mate 20 that's gonna be launching at the
same time the non pro is a physically
better looking phone on the outside it's
lacking all those facial unlock sensors
but it also means it loses that big
notch and it just has this dewdrop notch
as they call it in the middle that's
being used by a lot of companies now but
it's also clearly a step lower in a
couple other ways it's bigger but has a
lower resolution 1080p LCD not an OLED
and a slightly smaller 4000 milliamp
hour battery but it's just funny how the
lower end phone kind of seems a little
more visually appealing if you
we hate the knotch overall as a bi
though I don't think mate 20 pro is
gonna be like that critical phone that
everyone's paying attention to that you
necessarily have to buy it feels a lot
like they're throwing a lot of stuff at
the wall and hoping a lot of it sticks
like the stand out of that for me was
having a big cutout knotch
at the top of the screen for face ID
essentially when a lot of people don't
like notches and then also spending the
money on an under glass fingerprint
reader when pretty much everyone using a
phone will have to pick one or the other
and not use both seems like you're going
a little bit like spending extra here
and I get that having the option is
great but it felt like they should
probably commit to one or the other in
fact I'm pretty sure oneplus is gonna
commit to just a fingerprint reader and
not even make a big deal about still
having facial recognition with RGB
sensors and then on the software front
emui 9.0 it has a lot of small
improvements like in the settings and in
the stock apps but it's generally still
emui so if you didn't like it before
this isn't gonna change your mind but if
you did like the old one then this is a
little better so basically for me I
think I'm gonna be waiting for that P 30
Pro when it comes out to be their next
high-end flagship to test it out I'm
assuming the cameras gonna be great and
I'm gonna give it a shot
but let me know what you guys think of
this phone you think it's gonna think
it's gonna hold up do you think I should
have it in the camera comparison along
with the other high-end flagships it's a
lot of stuff we wonder about mate 20 Pro
either way until the next one thanks for
watching catch you later peace